here's what would happen if you jumped  into a pool full of Honey on a mild day  this honey would be incredibly thick  honey is a thixotropic fluid which means  if it stays still it becomes a gel-like  substance so that could slow your fall  now while your Cannonball wouldn't have  the same Splash as a wooden water the  sudden movement of your arms and legs  would begin to change the Honey's  composition and since your buoyant force  increases with density you may float  back to the top after you jump in  you might want to break out your swim  cap and Speedo to lessen the resistance  while you swim if you made this swim  part of your morning routine your skin  could become softer and well moisturized  your abrasions would heal faster and  you'd have fewer fungal infections what  are you up to You'll also get more than  a mouthful of honey while you're  swimming but take it easy if you eat too  much you could get sick or even die  so